when women
have these criteria for their man they
pick
20 of the male population generally 80
of women pick in their head 20 of the
male population so if so i'm asking so
if 20 of the male population have 80 of
the women to choose from
do you think what that one man is only
going to be sleeping with that one woman
i never saw no one as a woman coming
like oh i need a man you know like uh
please i'm alone all these eighty
percent of women have men and i don't
have police and if you marry i accept
you
i never saw that no but why are you
feeling about that but this is this is
what's happening so what's happening now
is when 80 of women are sleeping with 20
of men so women can say oh i don't like
polygamy i would never do that but we
pick the same guy you're already sharing
your guys so we need to go for ugly men
average guys like as i said
i said this on my podcast right average
men and average women are actually
missing each other like they're missing
each other they're missing like a whole
beat because there are average guys like
we talked about earlier on like the guys
that sit down and watch
corn hub and you know like
fans those type of guys are looking for
like women that are just like them
right but the women that are just like
them are looking at the 20 of guys and
it's like yo there's a load of guys here
but you're not looking at them you're
looking at those
other guys and it's like well there's
average men there's average women you
need to start
you know pairing with one another you
stop average women need to stop trying
to look for that 20 20 top 20 guy and
that's what i'm saying it would it would
even out a little bit but what happens
is that top 20 guy has all of these
women and the women start saying men are
trash men are trash that top 20 guy has
options
sometimes he exercises
i'm not saying that it's right
but sometimes he does because he's got
so many women looking for him because he
knows i said i know i'm six foot two i
know listen listen there's a load of
women looking for a six foot two guy but
even as a lot of women
there's a lot of men looking for meals
you know uh you know
no
your options decrease by
50 by the time you're 30.
so you have 50 percent
go with the steps boy
what is that no no look at sophia
you're actually you're right it does
depend how you look she looks good she
looks real good but she's still fifty
yeah and so what guys allow paul to make
her point sorry sorry
like like it's oh i'm sorry no you're
okay um
the the point is
i actually i don't even i don't even
have one
i do have a question when it comes to
men loving being able to love multiple
women is it the same type of love for
each woman or is there something that
like i love this about her i love that
about her it's not the same type of love
it's just different love but we know
that we actually love these women and
that's the thing it's like
um
women tend to think
like i'm not saying women think actually
love is not just one thing love is like
it's a subjective kind of construct
isn't it so
um i know i've been in love with two
women at the same time and i i know that
about myself that's the one that got
away
one of them did
no no no no no actually matter of fact
the one that got away i was just
but i'm just saying um yeah i've been in
love with two women at the same time and
i understand that the love that i had
for both of them was different i did
love both of them though so i know that
i'm just saying from personal experience
people can believe me or not believe me
i'm just saying i know from personal
experience that i can love more than one
woman at the same time so what was
different between the two
they just had different qualities
they just they just they stirred up a
different um
feeling
within me but both of the feelings that
they started with within me i liked both
of them do you know what i mean so it's
like i understood that um and this was
like way back in my 20s and stuff do you
know what i mean but i know that that
happened and i know that i've
experienced that so
i know that when people say oh no
polygamy a guy can have four wives or i
actually the last guy that i actually
one of my clients that i worked for he
had eight wives
get eight wives
out here from the streets he was from
swaziland
wow
he had like eight wives
yeah it's like in africa so it's like he
had like eight wives and it's like okay
cool so but then it like it brings us
back to like feminism i think is what
allowed this to be honest like like
women it's like okay now we sleep with
the same men but for no commitment so we
don't even before we at least got their
resources right but now we just got
their penis
now the penis that's it you just got
their penis that's it yeah like why
so i just i don't know what did feminism
give me and that's why i asked like what
in 2022 in the west do i need feminism
for
i can go work the same as a guy there's
nothing stopping me
um i can sleep with who i want if i get
pregnant i can go get an abortion
like what
i just i don't even know what in 2022 we
need it for
if anything
i want to return our rights
you want to do what return our rights
pearl wants to be a housewife
look it look it hear me out okay before
hear me out hear me out i'm listening
before
i got to sit at home okay i got to just
not work
i got to do nothing and just bear
children marry at 19. i don't even have
to do all the dating thing it's
exhausting right right yeah yeah now i
got a one pick my own husband my dad
used to be able to do that for me
i got to pay attention to politics now i
gotta vote i gotta drive
are you trying to bring that like the
1920s and stuff bro is that what's going
on her wants to go back in time she
wants to go back in time i gotta work
like what
why do we
but the thing is
so funny most women most women
if they had the option would not want to
work
if you had a guy that could take care of
you would you work would you do you want
to work i personally would because i
just like i mean it depends what you're
doing too but like if it's something i
love and i enjoy i'm going to want to do
it i don't want to just sit at home or
yeah i want to make my own income
i want to
just be able to have my own finance
let's say i didn't have a man
and i want like i want to be independent
and learn how to take care of myself and
obviously if someone comes in and
incorporates to that that's great so
like pearl said earlier on if drake says
okay cool i'm taking a date drake's a
multi-multi-millionaire and he's like
you know what i love you i love you
sasha you know what i don't want to
spend the rest of i'ma propose to you
you're going to be like yeah i'm a work
i
[Music]
i mean i like it depends like let's say
i had my own business and it's something
i genuinely want to do for like the rest
well not is it more of a hobby than the
more of a job that you'll be doing i
guess it's more of a hobby that i guess
right
now okay
i'm talking about work i'm talking about
going out and getting a wage
and going like
we're working on that like most of them
will not want to work if they get a guy
that's got the resources but we will do
something yeah you don't have a hobby
you have like a side hustle or a hobby
or something you know what the worst
part is all of the household chores are
automated now if we just waited until
like the 50s and the 60s yeah yeah bro
we could get a roomba
they got a roomba and the roomba with
the mop and the washer and dryer like
what
that is true you got a dishwasher
you can hire a maid
like you don't even have to do anything
pearl would be thriving
was like